I kind of need direction with that I
like I want I want to know exactly what
you're comfortable with so you're a
little scared to like make that move yes
well I've been waiting for you to make
that move hello and welcome to Split
Decision today we brought four straight
couples into the studio to ask them some
of the toughest most intimate questions
they have ever been asked forget your
partners behind you go with your gut and
most importantly be honest question
number one I've faked an orgasm with my
partner make your split decision in
three two one
okay go ahead and turn around
nothing guys have done it
that makes sense
to dive you've done it orgasm you were
my first like so in the very the
beginning of our relationship yeah I
just I it was hard for me to get into it
yeah in like the beginning did you know
first of all I did I did oh you knew she
fakes it yeah I do I did how did you
know it's pretty fake so I don't fake it
now I promise we met during High School
like sophomore year we've been together
for four years and married for two
Jenny
um he actually was not very good at the
beginning he sucked in the beginning not
anymore though nine more more though I I
think that I was sex life right now is
very pretty compatible but when we first
started dating like four or five months
in yeah I was doing that for like that
that time period
hmm I would eat the booty if my partner
asked me to
okay make your split decisions in uh
three uh two oh one
[Music]
okay turn around very very interesting
yo everybody says yes for the little ass
actually yeah okay okay have you all
done it no do you want him to ask
no okay ladies no I mean he asked you to
he's asking he's taking the initiative
he said babe please he already did he
already did I have asked and I said ask
so no success we've been together for
nearly 11 months now and we met through
hinge hinge success story I spent a long
time trying to find like the perfect
thing to say to catch her attention and
uh I got I got lucky I wish my partner
were more kinky and would take more
risks in bed make your split decisions
in three two a one
okay go ahead and turn around
[Laughter]
what Kinks just like in general other
stuff because
even though I do want it to be intimate
there are times where I do want it to be
like whoa you know like a little some
costume some toys I mean I like to dress
up I like lingerie I feel like that
would be that would make me feel sexier
tell us tell us what are you asking for
huh what do you want what do you want I
don't know we've been together for
almost five years now I I have a I have
a thing for maybe like
I don't even know if I can say this
maybe you're like doing stuff in public
like that's a that's a big like fetish
of mine okay
um have you told have you told them this
that you want to do stuff in public what
you mean is like public but in private
in the same time yeah like I mean people
can see it like a bathroom small like
okay in like a hidden spot on the beach
like
like that type of eye elevators I think
we have done a lot of that actually but
you want more
yeah all right Shady
um I feel like we're both in the same
place when it comes to getting kinkier
um I definitely want to explore like
everybody said toys and costumes and I I
do like being swept on my feet and I
know he'd like to see me in like a
school girl outfit I just want like to
take it to the next level really like
taking advantage of our bodies and like
this is mine like I'm gonna show you
like this is mine I want to be dominated
I kind of need direction with that I
like I want I want to know exactly what
you're comfortable with so you're a
little scared to like make that move yes
okay well I've been waiting for you to
make that move because you shouldn't
tell me I should make the move I will
make the move we've been dating for a
little over a year now she used to date
one of my best friends in high school
then they kind of
broke up and um together ever since yeah
I'm better at sex than my partner make
your split decisions in three two one
okay go ahead and turn around
yes okay
uh JD you're you both think you're
better at sex than the other person oh
okay
I want to hear more I said yes because I
seem to initiate it more and I feel like
I'm always putting myself out there and
I'm always you know trying to try new
things even if alcohol is not involved
um and you are kind of just passive in
the moment and I don't mind it but I
would like more an issue I will say that
you do definitely have
um more of the initiative side now but I
think that the uh the act of um
yeah the act of lovemaking
um I have pretty pretty down but to be
fair I am a lot easier and you are a lot
more difficult what do you mean he's
more difficult it's more difficult to
make finish it takes a while it takes a
long time if she was better at it would
it last a shorter amount of time
yes
when we first started dating it
definitely was much shorter because it
was new it was fun and not that it's bad
or anything like that
um but like it's
now I I found my groove and it's just
takes me a while maybe is that why you
don't initiate because it's not as good
as maybe once was no that's not why well
maybe get out of the groove and try new
things with me
and do what I want to do and we won't
have this problem okay okay this is why
you take the lead though no you
sh what do you want to do that he's not
doing I want more I want everything to
be different or different positions like
like all that kind of stuff you guys
just do one position right now it's just
missionary just it falls back into that
and I don't want to just sit there we
rotate sometimes sometimes on a good day
Alondra you're better at sex huh yeah I
think so I was his first so there wasn't
a lot to work with at the beginning I
feel like we have kind of the opposite
problem from them
I feel like he wants to have like sex
and I don't I wanted to be more into me
what is what is sex well you see on porn
or something or like in movies I wanted
to feel like he loves me I don't want it
to just feel like he wants to me I
want maybe a balance of both I do feel
like I'm kind of more the open-minded
one too I'm like okay well maybe we can
you know throw some of this throw some
of that in there I put no because like
you said I was she was my first like the
first time I was like
I've I already knew what's gonna happen
you know so I was like how can I make
this memorable
so before then I put like Kung Fu Panda
on so I could be like that's my movie
right there you know it's gonna be my
Kung Fu Panda you had you made love to
her with Kung Fu Panda Jack Black
spinning sticks yeah exactly yeah
because it's memorable you know yep and
then like
30 seconds later it's all over
at most the second time I was like oh
I'm gonna beat this you know I can't I
can't be I'm gonna put on Shrek instead
maybe 10 seconds and I'm like oh damn
Ted's that you were worse the second
time we've been together for a year and
10 months we were co-workers I was new
and he had been there a while and he
ignored me I was just nervous yeah he
says he was nervous I was like oh look
you know like do you have a girlfriend
and he was like no I was like perfect
you have one now I'm gonna be your
girlfriend I think my partner needs to
lose weight or exercise more make your
split decisions in three two one
here we go and turn around
okay
yes oh the only guy though
right yeah it doesn't necessarily mean
that you're fat or whatsoever just
basically we should move around more
it's funny that you're saying that
because I've been begging you to go to
the gym with me so you like working out
I don't find Joy but you want me to work
out okay no no
not work out but like you know move more
move around more most of the time she
only go to the gym if I say yes sure
we'll go to the gym yeah because I want
to go to the gym with you going to the
gym is very as a woman it's
you just feel like like a lot of men are
like staring at you so going with a
partner just makes me feel like a
hundred times better that's why I want
you to go with me so bad and you've
asked him to go with you I asked him
many times like how come you haven't
gone every week well she also asked me
in four in the morning
Devin has been telling me so many times
I want to get back to the gym but he
never goes Devin how does that make you
feel I mean not good it makes me feel a
bit lazy you know because I've been
promising
you know it's a get bigger and get
bigger muscles and stuff for months now
and I I mean I started I did start going
for a few months and then I just got
lazy again Shady you say yes Anthony you
say no
um I feel like we've been dating for a
year now so
um you've we've kind of like gotten that
relationship way and now we're more
comfortable with each other okay and you
complain about
gaining a little bit of weight well I
just have a little bit of a dad gut but
my partner is the most confident person
I've ever dated
make your split decisions in three two
one
and go ahead and turn around
[Music]
okay interesting through the gentleman
say yes three of the ladies say no
Alondra let's start with you I said no
because I think he's like
perfect in my eyes but he always has
something negative to say about himself
you know just from looking at him he has
a lot of good qualities a lot of good
features on him and he doesn't think
he's that attractive and I'm like uh
have you seen yourself
like you are very attractive if you want
to save to that okay so I've only ever
dated one other person before her
um it was an online or I mean long
distance we're pretty much the same I
guess very anxious and
like low self-esteem and whatever but
like like seeing her do the things she
um does like it inspires me because I
want to be
more like her
damn exactly
no just just everything she does I just
want to be more like her in that in that
regard you know she's she's amazing so
Jenny Devin is the most confident person
you have ever been with but Devin Jenny
is not the most confident you've ever
been with no no no big no okay like
where is she at one to ten I would say
honestly I would say you're at like uh
like a five or a six
and I think we could we could probably
move that on out where do you feel you
are what's your one to ten
three
I think I think for me it's like my
upbringing where I where I'm from I'm uh
I grew up in Asia yeah as an Asian thing
yeah there you go thank you uh Takahashi
I get it all right
been there my friends
yeah but he's the most confident you've
ever been with yeah I like it though how
many guys have you been with
he's my fourth boyfriend fourth okay and
what's what's he at one to ten
I would say he's uh nine really yeah
yeah wow okay I'll take that one of
these all right all right let's go on to
the Moon let's move on to the next
question everybody my family approves of
my partner make your split decisions in
three two one
all right go ahead and turn around
no huh I came from a very very cultural
uh family uh my parents Works definitely
expecting me to date my own race in a
way so
besides that a lot of cultural
difference as well that my family did
not go well with and is that still going
on they still don't still going on still
working on it at the moment for me how
does that make you feel
it's been probably the
be so bad to be accepted yeah
um
and one day hopefully have a
relationship with your family and then
it also like just brings a lot of
insecurities in myself like I'm not like
good enough and to a point it kind of
starting to make me a question if I'm
accepted too in a way because of the
relationship as well so it's been tough
for that
yeah biggest mountain we ever got to
climb
and you say no as well
what's the story well I say no because
my mom she's like very old traditional
like Mexican mom and she expects a lot
from my partner regardless of who they
are she really expects a lot like she
needs some to kind of work their entire
life work away the only thing they think
about is like working and not anything
outside of that and the man is supposed
to take care of everything I mean I
haven't told him this but my mom thinks
that he has a lot of free time and she
hates that I mean she likes him as a
person because he's a really good person
but she just feels like he should be
more like man how do you all feel about
those you know traditional gender Norms
like what we're talking about right here
definitely for me and Anthony we're very
not based on that
um for the longest time I was working
two jobs and I was bringing in the
income and taking care of rent while he
was you know not working as much and
waiting for a promotion so he can get to
that step but I do believe like a
relationship is whatever you can give
it's not all 100 it's not you know just
50 50. it's if I come home one day and I
worked really hard and I'm too tired to
do the dishes he's going to come in and
do the dishes there is a political issue
that my partner and I will never agree
on
[Music]
turn around
okay
Anthony
what's going on
well whenever it kind of comes to
politics I feel like we're
kind of a different mindset because of
how we're like raised different mindset
yeah different mindset I she's very um
anti-government I'm not anti-government
I'm I'm kind of like I wish the
government worked more for us okay I
didn't know that we disagreed on that so
I'm over here
um I don't want to live in California I
don't want to live in the United States
I don't like the government and you know
what we have going on right now if the
diversity is is great but it's just
causing more and more problems my dream
is to like run away live in a forest
survive off of my own abilities like be
self-efficient I don't want to live in
the United States and if it was up to me
I wouldn't but you thought you were on
the same page about that I thought yeah
I thought we agreed that you know we
would move away and you know the
government it would be nice but
do you want to move to a forest and
I like my air conditioning I like my
video games
Alondra
you say yes
well I was stuck in between yes and no
because I'm I don't feel like it's an
actual issue but um I'm not completely
against abortion I just don't think I
guess it's fair to the life inside of
you I know a lot of people say it's not
life to me in my conscious it's life
even if you have a 30 chance or even if
I have a 30 chance of dying like I want
my baby to live when we brought that up
I was like What if I got pregnant and I
had a 30 chance of dying like would you
be would break up with me if I aborted
it and she was like yeah I'm like that
oh you would break up with him if he
aborted the baby I would I wouldn't want
to be with someone that doesn't agree
with me on that stance because it's also
my child are you okay that he's okay
with it no I don't like that
Bernice
um during quarantine with the whole BLM
it was like really affecting my
community the most with like police
brutality and everything that was going
on I felt like it was hard for you to
understand or like really understand how
important it was to me to like go to
these protests and really like be there
for my community yeah it was kind of
hard for you to understand how much
that meant to me what did I disagree on
again on that one
um it was it was two years three years
yeah it was it was just some like it
felt like you were you were telling me
like oh well you know you shouldn't be
going to these protests because like
they're dangerous or they were like they
they weren't dangerous the protest I was
going to like yeah it was dangerous
I don't think I say it was dangerous
what did you say I was trying to like
you know understand her intention of
going to the floor test like get your
head straight before you action act on
something yeah I don't want you to go
acting something without getting a
history in a way what do you mean by
that by understanding your intention why
are you going what are and what am I
gaining out is some questions I never
even thought about before
so like it brought up like things that
happened like years ago I learned about
Devin today was that he has been pretty
open to me honestly yeah it's it's good
to know to go deeper into like the
topics for sure but I kind of expected
what would happen being here today it
kind of just made at least me feel like
I'm with the right person like I want to
continue this I want to stick it out and
hopefully it goes somewhere me too